all right my dear what an evening  he's right yeah how about that moment  with Chad Jordan is a liar cheater who's  the one older brother who won't even  talk to us  I could go off right now if you had chat  alone in a room what would you say to  Chad I have so much in my head of what I  could say but if I try to get it all out  I feel like I would just get like just  messed up on my own word so I will just  leave it I think it's bizarre and I  think that he loves the attention and  that's I don't wanna give it to him with  how you said that you're like I'm not  gonna waste my breath I will say that  the one thing that has been so crazy is  just I you know I got to know Chad for  who I thought he was in the show and I  you know I gave him that respect and I  feel like a lot of people tried to give  him the same respect and just I think  afterwards just the social media antics  of what's been going on it's crazy to me